[موسيقى]
تحياتي لكم اعزائي المشاهدين هذه نشره
التاسعه هذا المساء يقدمها لكم العناوين
[موسيقى]
ترامب يتوجه الى نيويورك تمهيدا لمثوله
امام المحكمه غدا العالم يترقب محاكمه
القرن
والبيت الابيض يؤكد عدم رصد اي تهديدات
بسبب محاكمه ترامب ويشدد على يقظه الاجهزه
الامنيه
تستعد للانضمام غدا لحلف النيتو رسميا
وروسيا تؤكد تعزيز وجودها العسكري
استراليا احدث المنضمين لمقاطعه تيك توك
حظر قريب للتطبيق على الاجهزه الحكوميه
[موسيقى]
ترقب عالمي اذا للحدث الابرز غدا حيث يمثل
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب امام
محكمه منهاتن في مثل هذا التوقيت من مساء
الغد اجراءات امنيه مشدده في نيويورك
وتحسب لعاصفه سياسيه في واشنطن في ظل
استقطاب شديد للحده بين الحزبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطي هذا هو ملفنا الاول في
التاسعه
[موسيقى]
اذا غادر الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب فلوريدا متجها الى نيويورك حيث
يتوقع ان يحتجز في انتظار محاكمته في
الاتهامات بدفع اموال لممثله افلام اباحيه
لشراء صمتها ابن حملته الانتخابيه عام
2016 ترامب اعلن انه سيتوجه الى منهات بعد
ظهر اليوم وسيزور برج ترامب قبل ان يسلم
نفسه للسلطات غدا ويخطط انصار تشامب
لتنظيم تجمع حاشد في نيويورك صباح الغد
وبينما يركز خصومه رئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب على قضيته الجنائيه لادانته على
مسرح محكمه نيويورك امام العالم اجمع
ترامب يزداد توجهه ويعزز هويته الوطنيه
ويروج لحملته تحضيرا للسباق الرئاسي
القادم ويختزل قضيه اتهامه بوضعها على
هامش الطريق هكذا قرات صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز سلوكا ترامب الذي تعامل بذكاء مع
قضيته الجنائيه واعتبرها مشهدا عابرا
وليست قضيه خطيره لدرجه انه شوه مصداقيتها
على الاقل في نظر مؤيديه وبدلا من
الاختباء من اهانه تسليم نفسه الى السلطات
ارسل ترامب جدلا زمنيا كما لو كان في جوله
انتخابيه ليخبر الجميع بكل خطواته قبل
وصوله الى محكمه نيويورك وارسل ترامب
بريدا الكترونيا لجمع التبرعات بعناوين
يخشاها السياسيون الاخرون مثل الرئيس
المتهم نعم لقد تم اتهامي ولكن وهذه
العناوين رد عليها مؤيدوه باعطائه المال
ووصل المبلغ الى اربعه ملايين دولار خلال
24 ساعه فقط بعد صدور قرار اتهامه وعدا عن
ذلك مشاهدينا ترامب الذي يقترب من عقده
التاسع يبقى المرشح المفضل لدى حزبه
الجمهوري بعدما كشفت اخر استطلاعات الراي
تقدمه في الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب
الجمهوري لعام 2004
مجله نيوزويك الامريكيه بدورها اعتبرت ان
مدعي عام منهاتنبراج اعاد انتخاب ترامب
مره اخرى لان ادعاءاته مشكوك بها واستندت
نيوزويك ايضا الى تقارير نشرتها صحيفه
واشنطن بوست المناهضه بشده تقول فيها ان
اتهامات المدعي العام براج غير مقنعه وان
المحاكمه يجب الا تستمر لان براج نفسه غير
مقتنع بتجريم ترامب لانه تخلى عن القضيه
قبل عام ولم يعد احيائها او لم يعد
احيائها الا بعد ان تعرض للخذلان من قبل
اثنين من اتباعه بعد استقالتهما بسبب هذا
القرار
الاستعداد لمعركه هذا ما يقوم به الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب قبل جلسه
محاكمته المقرره الثلاثاء وفق محاميه من
المتوقع ان يسافر ترامب الى مدينه نيويورك
برفقه اعضاء من الخدمه السريه الامريكيه
من منزله في مارلاجو الاثنين ثم يخطط
للعوده الى فلوريدا بعد جلسه محاكمته حيث
سيخاطب انصاره بحسب محاميه ستحارب اي
اتهامات ضد الرئيس السابق بقوه وسيمثل
امام محكمه نيويورك لابلاغه بتهمه جنائيه
موجهه اليه في قضيه دفع اموال لممثله
اباحيه بغيه شراء صمتها من المتوقع ان
يسلم نفسه للسلطات يوم الثلاثاء ومن
المقرر عقد جلسه استماع ظهرا في منهات ولن
تقيد يدات ترامب وبحسب محاميه التفاصيل
الاخرى للاستدعاء لا تزال غامضه بحكمه انه
امر غير مسبوق لا تزال تفاصيل التهم بما
في ذلك مهيتها وعددها طي الكتمان وفق
محاميه وسط نفيا بارتكابها من قبل ترامب
تقارير اعلاميه افادت بان ترامب سيواجهه
اكثر من 30 تهمه تتعلق بالاحتيال التجاري
لدفع 130 الف دولار
في عام 2016 في محاوله لشراء صمتها بشان
علاقه جنسيه مزعومه وسائل اعلام امريكيه
ذكرت بان ترامب متهم بتزوير سجلات تجاريه
من الدرجه الاولى وهي جنايه بموجب القانون
الامريكي ومن المقرر تنظيم تجمع حاشد
لترامب مع النائبه الجمهوريه في مجلس
النواب مارجريت هيلر جرين ظهر الثلاثاء
بنيويورك داعيه ان صار ترامب للانضمام الى
احتجاج سلمي ضد لائحه الاتهام رش خياط
العربيه
هذا واكد عمده نيويورك ادمز انه لا توجد
تهديدات جديه على امن المدينه خلال محاكمه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب وحذر عمده
نيويورك من انه سيتم القاء القبض على اي
شخص يتورط في عنف خلال محاكمه الرئيس
السابق
لجبريل مدينه نيويورك دائما مستعده نعلم
ان السلطات انفاذ القانون في المدينه يجب
ان تكون مستعده لاي شيء قد يحدث اريد ان
اوضح اننا لن نتلقى ايه تهديدات كبرى
محدده للمدينه خلال توقيت المحاكمه
اذا نتابع المشهد من نيويورك التي تحبس
انفاسها مع انتظار مثول ترامب من امام
ترامبور في نيويورك ناديه بلبيسي مديره
مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ومن امام محكمه
الجنايات في ملهاتنا في نيويورك ايضا طلال
الحاج مراسل العربيه مرحبا بكما ناديه
ابدا معك ترامب من المنتظر ان يصل الى
منزله في ترامب تاور بعد حوالي ساعه من
الان ما هي الصوره لديك هناك امام
بالفعل صهيب بنتوقع وصول الرئيس الى هنا
في وسط منهات سيكون على متن طائرته الخاصه
مع مجموعه من مستشاريع سيمكث في بيته في
منزله في هذه الشقه التي كانت بالنسبه له
ربما
ترتبط بذكريات كبيره لانه كان يقيم في
ولايه نيويورك بعدما قرر هجرها تماما
والاقامه في ولايه فلوريدا طبعا محموه قبل
قليل قالوا بانهم لن يسمحوا لي الكاميرات
بالدخول الى قاعه المحكمه وكان هذا الطلب
من وسائل الاعلام المتواجده امام هناك الف
يمكن تقريبا صحفي متواجد حاليا الان وطبعا
هناك تغطيه اعلاميه كثيفه جدا لهذا الرجل
الذي دوما دوما يعرف كيف يجذب الاعلام
بالنسبه له وطبعا غدا بعد لقائه مع محاميه
امام المحكمه وبعد مثول طبعا لفتره قصيره
سيتوجه الى مره اخرى الى فلوريدا لنتوقع
الخطاب الاهم ربما في بالنسبه للرئيس
ترامب وهو خطاب وجهه للشعب الامريكي
لمعيده ولمناصره لاقول بان هذه التهم
باطله طبعا هو لن يقر بالذنب وسيقول بانه
بريء منها تماما وهي المحكمه التي يقف
امامها طلال الحاج الان في هذه اللحظات
طلال اذا ترامب يعود الى دياره يعود الى
نيويورك من فلوريدا ولكن هذه المره ليمثل
امام القاضي غدا ما هي الترتيبات
نعم يعود الى
منزله السابق فهو ليس من سكان
نيويورك رسميا حيث نقل مقر سكني الى
فلوريدا بصوره نهائيه حتى هذه اللحظه
سوف يقف امام القاضي وسوف يعرض عليه
القاضي قراءه التهم الموجهه اليه ونتوقع
ان تكون نحو 34 تهمه 34 تهمه بالتحديد
وبعد ذلك سيقوم بتوزيعها على
المحامين حيث ليست لديهم نسخه من هذه
التهم حتى الان وعلى الادعاء وسنعلم جميعا
ما هي هذه التهم وهي كما تعرف
صهيب مبنيه على الاحتيال في الاعمال وهي
في الكثير من الاحياء الجنح وليس الجرائم
ولكن اذا استخدمت هذه الجنحه في التغطيه
الجريمه تعتبر وفقا لقانون ولايه ولايه
نيويورك جريمه وحكم
احد
مستشاريه ومحاميه السابق في هذه التهمه
وسجن عام 2018
لمده
ثلاثه عشر شهرا
وفرضت عليه اقامه اجباريه بسبب ادانته
بتغطيه ودفع الريشه او الرشاوي الى ستور
ميدانيا ولذلك يجادل الكثيرون هنا من
الديمقراطين لماذا ينطبق هذا على مايكل
كون ويسجن ويصبح
مرتكبا لجنايه بينما يقولون عن التام موجه
الى
انها بدعه سياسيه وقضيه مسيسه ناديه اعود
اليك ما المعلومات المتوفره عن الاجراءات
كذلك التي سيخضع لها سنشاهد ترامب يلتقط
له الصور كما المجرمين بعد اخذ البصمات
وسيوضع في زنزانه ام سيعامل معامله خاصه
لانه رايق
لا استطيع ان اقول معامله خاصه لكن بسبب
انه رئيس سابق اولا الشرطه السريه ستكون
معه وعندما يدخل الى قاعه المحكمه سيتم
اخذ بصمتك كما ذكرت لكن يبدو انه هناك
اتفاق مع محاميه بان يتم التقاط ما يسمى
اي صوره له لماذا تتخذ هذه الصوره مع
الاشخاص المتهمين بجرائم مماثله حتى يتعرف
عليها
العامه يعني او الناس لكن لانه ترامب
شخصيه كان رئيس سابق ومترجح للرئاسات
القادمه فلم يرى بان هناك ربما ضروره لاخذ
هذه الصوره عدا عن التخوف من تسربها طبعا
الى
الخارجين له الى اخره لكن على كل الاحوال
لا نتوقع ايضا مظاهرات عنيفه يعني هناك
انتشار كبير لشرطه نيويورك هنا في ترامبور
وحول المحكمه 30 الف عنصر من رجال الشرطه
والاف بي اي وعلى هناك ملاحظه ربما ملفته
للانظار وهي عدم وجود مؤيدين رئيسنا يعني
انا لي تقريبا ساعه ونصف في هذا المكان
لما ارى شخص واحد يؤيد ترامب او يحمل شعار
له واعتقد ان السيناريو الذي كان
يقارن بما حدث في سته يناير لن يتكرر انه
الظروف مختلفه تماما كان هناك حديث طبعا
كما تعرف عنه شرعيه الانتخابات والان
نتحدث عن اتهامات مع ممثله اباحيه تفضل
المؤيد لم يخرجوا بعد طلال ولكن هناك
محاذير كبيره جدا واحتماليه حدوث اعمال
عنف ما الذي نعرفه عن نوايا انصار ترامب
والمخاوف والمحاذير المتعلقه بيوم غد بيوم
مثول الرئيس السابق امام المحكمه في
منهاتن
نعم ما جيت الاقرين وهي نائبه اليمنيه في
مجلس النواب والتي تامل ان تكون حليفه او
قرينه
ترامب في
[موسيقى]
حملتي الانتخابيه والوقوف كنائبه له اذا
نجح في الانتخابات هذا هو املها دعت
الجميع للحضور الى هنا الى هذه الساحه
للتظاهر يوم وغدا احب ان اذكر ان اعداد
الشرطه هنا نحو اكثر من 36 الف شرطي في
ولايه في مدينه نيويورك اكبر جهاز للشرطه
في المدينه في اي مدينه امريكيه والشيء
الثاني الذي نفهمه من المحامي هو انهم لن
يكبلوه ولن ياخذون له ولن
وسيقومون باخذ اصابعه هي طمغات الاصابع
ولكن شيء الذي لم ينتهوا بعد من التفاوض
عليه هو نعم بصمات الاصابع نعم هو اخذ
الصور له لما يسمى بالمقشط او عدمها حتى
هذه اللحظه لا يوجد تاكيد بانهم لن ياخذوا
له الصور داخل هذه المحكمه ايضا القاضي
طلب منه من قبل الشركات الامريكيه
الاعلاميه والاجنبيه ان يسمح بوجود
كاميرات في هذه الجلسه القادمه لم يتخذ
قراره بعد ولكن نعرف ان جهاز المحاماه
لرئيس ترامب عرض هذه الفكره
ورفضها ولكن القاضي لم يقل فيها كلمته
الاخيره ستوجد كاميرا واحده في الطابق
الخامس عشر ولكن ليست في داخل القاعه
وانما ستصور ترامبو وهو يدخل قاعه المحكمه
حتى هذه اللحظه نعم شكرا جزيلا لكما حتى
الان اذا طلال الحاجه انت امام المحكمه
الجنائيه في منهاتن حيث سيمثل غدا وناديه
بلبيسي مديره مكتب العربيه انت امام ترامب
تاور حيث سيقيم ترامب وسيصل اليه بعد اقل
من ساعه من الان استعدادا لمثوله غدا امام
القاضي شكرا جزيلا لكم حتى الان سنتابع
معكما تطورات هذه القصه او الان باول شكرا
حتى الان
شهدت ساحه السياسيه الامريكيه والتراث
بسبب الاتهامات التي تم توجيهها الى
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامبو مخاوف من
تصعيد امني شبيه باحداث الكابيتول المزيد
في التقرير التالي
مع اختلاف طبيعه مثول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه بتهم
جنائيه واحداث الكابيتول الا ان هناك
مخاوف من تكرار ذات السيناريو فوضى وعنف
وتخريب رغم ان مؤشرات ذلك قليله وفقا
للسلطات الامنيه الامريكيه لكن لمعرفه
الاختلافات بين المناسبتين يجب اولا
التذكير باحداث الكابيتول
شغب الكابيتول حدث عام 2021 حين اقدم حشد
عنيف من انصار الرئيس دونالد ترامب على
مهاجمه مبنى الكابيتول في العاصمه واشنطن
احداث فتحت معها اكبر تحقيق في تاريخ
وزاره العدل الامريكيه ويواجه اكثر من 930
شخصا اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم فيدراليه
الامر المشترك ما بين احداث الكابيتول
وبين مثول ترامب امام المحكمه بقضايا
جنائيه هو خطاب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
لمناصريه لكن المختلف هو توقيت الخطابين
في احداث الكابيتول كان خطابه ناريا
ظهر فيه قبل ساعات من الواقعه واثار
المئات من انصاره اما فيما يتعلق بمحاكمته
في منهات فاعلن الرئيس الامريكي انه سيظهر
علنا بخطاب لكن هذه المره بعد ساعات من
سماعه لائحه الاتهام الموجهه له فحوى
الخطاب غير معروفه حتى الان لكن المعروف
هو تاثير ترامب على انصاره وفي المقابل
ردات الفعل غير المتوقعه للمناهضين له
احداث الكابيتول مثلت درسا للسلطات
الامنيه بدات بعدها بمسح امني واسع
للمشاركين وتبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
بشكل اسرع وعلى الارض تجهيز مواقع الحدث
بحواجز معدنيه واغلاق الطرق وحتى قوى
بشريه ضخمه تغطي مساحه واسعه استعدادا لاي
طارئ
الرئيس الامريكي السابق صرح داخل الدائره
المحيطه به بانه سيلاحق مدعي عاما هاتن
الذي تسبب في عوده وعوده واحده من القضايا
المنسيه
اسم يهدد مستقبل ترامب السياسي بسببه يمثل
الرئيس الامريكي السابق امام المحكمه
للاستماع للائحه اتهامات طويله
مدعي عام منهج خصم ترامب القضائي الجديد
انما مشى قضيه تعتبر منسيه للعامه قضيه
الممثله الاباحيه
[موسيقى]
بانهم مستعدوا لتصعيد الهجمات والثاني من
مدعي عاما هاجر
بالفعل الى انه سيلاحق مدعي عاما هاتا قبل
اسابيع من تسلمه لائحه الاتهام ووصفه
بالمختل عقلي
معنى من واشنطن ايهاب عباس المحلل
السياسيه استاذ ايهاب اهلا بك معنا هل
قضيه التوجيه الاتهام الى برايك برمتها هي
قضيه سياسيه
مدعي عامه هو ديمقراطي
اهلا بحضرتك استاذ صهيب واهلا بكل
المشاهدين يعني بالفعل انا من الممكن ان
اضعها في هذا الاطار بشكل كبير جدا يعني
هي قضيه بالفعل موجوده ولكن يتم استغلالها
سياسيا لا نقول انها اخترعت من لا شيء هي
موجوده بالفعل ولكن منذ عام 2016
والتحقيقات جاريه فيها منذ ذلك الحين وكما
يقول التقرير لديكم واصبحت منسيه للعامه
لكن هذا لا يعني ان العداله لا يجد ان
تاخذ مجراها فهي تاخذ مجراها في الوقت
الذي تبدو فيه العمليه كما لو كانت مسيسه
هل هي مسيسه بالفعل ام لا هذا ما ستتكشف
عنه في الواقع الحقائق عندما تبدا سير
عمليات توجيه الاتهام الرسمي بالفعل
والتحقيقات الجلديه التي ربما تصل الى
ادانه من عدمه اذا وصلت الى ادانه تقبل
القانون والدستور الامريكي سنقول انها
طبيعيه واخذت فقط يعني مصادفه توقيتا
سياسيا لكن اذا لم تصل لاي شيء ولكل تاكيد
ولكن على الحالتين استاذ ايهاب هناك من
يرى انه مدعي عام قدم افضل هديه لدونالد
ترامب لانه هو يريد ان يظهر بانه مستهدف
وبانه معتقل حتى يظهر بمظهر الضحيه
وبالتالي يكون لديه مؤيدين اكثر هل برايك
يحسن حتى الان استثمار هذه القضيه
بكل تاكيد ترامب رجل الاعمال ذكي يستطيع
ان يحشد لديه قدره على الخطاب الشعبوي
تحديدا من شانها ان تجعل محبيه يستثارون
ويتوجهون لاي مكان يدعوهم اليه ويفكرون في
اي شيء يدعوهم اليه وهو استطاع خلال
السنوات الست التي ظهر فيها على الساحه
السياسيه بشكل كبير منذ الانتخابات في عام
2015 ثمان سنوات ايضا وحتى اللحظه استطاع
الرجل ان يكون لديه قاعده شعبيه عريضه جدا
ايهاب لكن يعني بالنسبه
للمتعاطفين مع ترامب بالنهايه هي قضيه
اخلاقيه هو قام باقامه علاقه خارج اطار
الزواج مع ممثله اباحيه ودفع لها اموال
حتى تسكت عن هذه العلاقه كيف يمكن
للامريكيين ان يتعاطفوا معه اكثر في قضيه
كهذه
استاذ صهيب هناك يعني خطا في توصيف هذه
القضيه بانها قضيه اخلاقيه طبقا للمنظور
الامريكي بالمناسبه وليس لمنظورات اخرى
بمعنى هذه القضيه هي قضيه صرف اموال
متعلقه بانتخابات بحمله انتخابيه في مجال
غير المجال الذي جمعت من اجله ترامب لا
يحاكم لانه اقام علاقه غير شرعيه في اطار
خارج الزواج او ان المجتمع الامريكي يرحب
بمثل هذه الفكره او لا يرحب لا الامريكيين
لا يشغلهم هذه العلاقه على الاطلاق انما
يشغلهم ويشغل القضاء فكره ان ترامب نعم
بدفع اموال اموال
الحمله الانتخابيه
لاسكات الشخص عن كشف علاقه اقامها معه هذا
رئيس دونالد ترامب يعني الفكره في دفع
الاموال وما سيوجه اليه من اتهامات سيكون
بعيدا تماما عن اقامته علاقه شرعيه من
عدمها
اموال اكثر منها مساله العلاقه في الحد
ممتاز طيب استاذ ايهاب ارجو ان تتفضل
بالبقاء مع ناس ساعود اليك بعد قليل في
زاويه اخرى من هذا الملف مشاهدينا حيث قال
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ان انتخابات عام
2020 مزوره ومسروقه مشددا على استعادتها
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله في عام
2024 مشيرا ايضا الى ان الهجمات التي
استهدفته لم يشهدها اي رئيس اخر في تاريخ
امريكا
لم يتعرض اي رئيس في تاريخ بلدنا لمثل هذه
الهجمات الشرسه والمثيره للاشمئزاز لكنهم
يهاجمونني فقط لانني اقاتل من اجلكم هذا
بسيط جدا لا يمكنهم شرائي ولا يمكنهم
التحكم به وهذا يخيفهم بشكل لا يصدق تمويل
حملاتنا الرئاسيه دائما كان من قبل
الوطنيين من القاعده الشعبيه مثلكم
مساهمتكم اليوم ستظهر لليسار انه لا شيء
يمكن ان يدمر اعظم حركه سياسيه في التاريخ
حققنا اداء افضل بعده ملايين وملايين
الاصوات في عام 2020 لكن الانتخابات تم
تزويرها وسرقتها ولكن اليوم سنستعيد بلدنا
في عام 2024
اعد الى ضيفي في واشنطن العاصمه الاستاذ
ايهاب عباس استاذ ايهاب اهلا بك معنا مره
اخرى لماذا ما يزال ترامب يوزر على ان
الانتخابات التي خسرها امام بايدن في 2020
هي انتخابات مزوره ومسروقه
نعم يعني هي وجهه نظر لديه يحاول ان
يصدرها دائما للمجتمع الامريكي واليوم
اصبح يؤكد على هذه المعلومه بشكل كبير جدا
خاصه بعد فوز الجمهوريين
بالاغلبيه حتى ولو كانت بسيطه في مجلس
النواب وعودته لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
التي حرم منها خلال العامين الماضيين
فاصبح الرجل من جديد يروج لهذه الفكره
ويعلم ان لها صدى كبير لدى اعضاء الحزب
الجمهوري والقيادات السياسيه وايضا اعضاء
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب والشيوخ وطبعا
قاعده العريضه الشعبيه الامريكيه التي
ذهبت انتخابه وهي بالفعل في الواقع تؤتي
اكلها وثمارها لان الجميع
نتحدث الان ترامب غرد على منصته المفضله
للتواصل الاجتماعي تروس سوشل هو يقول انا
ذاهب الى نيويورك لنجعل امريكا عظيمه
مجددا وهو شعاره الانتخابي ايضا ويقول
ايضا في هذه التغريده هذه اضطهاد ودولتنا
تتجه الى الجحيم يعني هذا نفس الاطار الذي
نتحدث عنه هو يحاول استغلال يعني هذه
القضيه احسن استثمار لجلب المزيد من
التاييد له وهنا تحضرني كذلك تغريده ايلون
ماسك الذي قال اذا اعتقل دونالد ترامب
فانه سيربح الانتخابات القادمه في 2024
باكتساح
ماذا نتوقع الان من سيناريوهات مع اقتراب
من ثول ترامب امام القاضي في منهات الغدا
انا اعتقد اننا سنكون امام ثلاثه
سيناريوهات السيناريو الاول هو طبعا توجيه
لائحه الاتهام وبدء المحاكمه وعدم وضوح
الرؤيه لمده اشهر هذا سيعطي ترامب زخما
كبيرا في حملته الانتخابيه
وسيجعله يعني قبق قوسين او ادنى من ان
يكون المرشح الاوفر حظا للحزب الجمهوري
لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه واتفق
مع الماسك في مقاله من انه من الممكن ان
يفوز باتساع بسبب هذه القضيه السيناريو
الاخر ان هذه القضيه لن تسفر عن اي شيء
وسيستطيع محاموها القضاء على هذه القضيه
ووادها في هذه المرحله وستكون هنا صفعه
كبيره جدا على وجه الفمبراج مدعيا وايضا
لكل السياسيين والديمقراطيين الذين اكدوا
ان ترامب خلف القانون وانها فرصه لاثبات
ان القانون يتفوق على الجميع
وعندها طبعا ستكون فرصه
تفضل السيناريو الثالث لو سمحت نعم قبل
الثالث هو ان تتم الادانه وتكون هناك يعني
محاكمه وادانه وسجن حتى لترانك وايضا
سيدخل الانتخابات وربما يفوز بها ويكون
مارس ولكن هناك عامل مفصلي هنا ايضا استاذ
الحزب الديمقراطي ومدعيا بانه من الحزب
الديمقراطي لكن ماذا عن الحزب الجمهوري هل
الجمهوريون الان في هذه المرحله يدعمون
ترامب رغم هذه القضيه ايضا ام سيدعمون
مرشحا جمهوريا اخر مثل ديسانتس مثلا
انا كنت اتوقع هذا الامر بشكل او باخر
يكون هناك جدلا حوله لكن ما اشاهده الان
من قيادات الحزب الجمهوري ومن اعضائه حتى
في وسط السن وطبعا الغالبيه المنتمين
للحزب قلبا وقالبا يبدو انه ملتفون حتى
الان على قلب رجل واحد حول ترامب هم
يعلمون ان سقوط ترامب سيؤدي الى سقوط
الحزب هو الشخصيه الاوفر حظا والضربه لن
تكون ضربه للترامب بشخصي ولكن ضربه للحزب
الجمهوري ككل وحتى
المنافس المحتمل والاكبر والاشرس لترامب
متعاطف مع الرئيس ويعتقد هو الاخر ان ما
يحدث مع ترامب هو محاوله لما يسمى او
النيل منه سياسيا
وتعجيزه عن خوض الانتخابات ايهاب عباس
شكرا جزيلا لك على انضمامك الينا مباشره
من واشنطن العاصمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نضوي ملف محاكمه ترامب ونذهب الى فاصل في
التاسعه نتابع فيها بعد قليل تسجيل اصابات
جديده بفيروس ماربورج والصحه العالميه
تواصل تحذيراتها
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد نقله وكاله فارس
للانباء عن نائب الرئيس الايراني محمد
مخبر قوله ان رئيس البلاد ابراهيم رئيسي
سيزور السعوديه وقال نائب الرئيس الايراني
انه من المتوقع ان تخرج نتائج جيده من هذه
الزياره وكانت السعوديه وايران توصلت الى
اتفاق الاستئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
بينهما برعايه صينيه
[موسيقى]
فنلندا ستصبح غدا عضوا رسميا في حلف شمال
الاطلسي بعد ان صادقت جميع دول حلف النيتو
البالغ عددها 30 على بروتوكول انضمامها
ووصف امينو عام
القرار بالتاريخي مؤكدا انه سيجعل فنلندا
اكثر امانا ومع هذا القرار تكون في لندن
انضمت قبل السويد الى حلف النيتو بسبب
استمرار معارضه تركيا في المقابل نددت
موسكو الاسبوع الماضي بقرار انضمام فنلندا
والسويد الى النيتو معتبره ان روسيا لا
تشكل تهديدا لهذين البلدين وتقدمت كل من
السويد وفنلندا بطلب للانضمام الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي بعد بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا
اذ وجدتها في الحرب تهديدا روسيا كبيرا
للامن الاوروبي
هذا اسبوع تاريخي للنيتو غدا سنععلن
ترحيبنا بانضمام فنلندا لحلف الناتو العضو
رقم 31 ما سيجعل من فنلندا اكثر امانا
والحلف سيزداد قوه كذلك السويد ستصبح اكثر
امنا وكان هذا نتاج الدعوه التي قدمها
النيتو لانضمام فنلندا والسويد للحلف
العام الماضي وكانت اجراءات اتمامها سريعه
بالنسبه للحلف وكلنا نتفق على ضروره انهاء
اجراءات انضمام السويد بشكل سريع
[موسيقى]
عقب زعيم قوه الروسيه السيطره على مدينه
باكموت ورفع العلم الروسي وسط المدينه كيف
تنفي وتقول ان باخمت ما زالت اوكرانيا فما
الذي يحدث في مدينه اطول معركه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه
انه الثاني من ابريل وخلفي يوجد مبنى
اداره مدينه باخموت من الناحيه القانونيه
لقد اخذنا باخموت وسيرفع قاده الوحدات
التي استولت على مبنى الاداره والمنطقه
المركزيه باكملها هذه الاعلام العدو لا
يزال متمركزا في الاجزاء الغربيه من
المدينه
كان هذا الحديث ليفدين زعيم قوات فاجنر
الروسيه حديث رد عليه المتحدث باسم
القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه الشرقيه
لقد رفعوا العلم على مراحيض رفعوه في مكان
مجهول علقوا قطعه قماش وقالوا انهم
استولوا على المدينه حسنا فلندعهم يعتقدون
انهم استولوا عليها تقول المعلومات ان
اشتداد حده التصريحات بين الطرفين يعكس
اشتداد حراره المعارك بينهما امر لم
ينفهتى ولا حتى الرئيس الاوكراني
الاجواء مشتعله في باخمه اليوم على وجه
الخصوص بالقرب من بيلوريفيكا وكريميا
وجميع مدننا وبلداتنا وقران الاخرى في
دومباس
وفقا لتصريحات الجانبين فان المعارك تدور
على الضفه الغربيه من النهر الذي يشطر
المدينه الى نصفين في محيط مبنى مجلس
باخموت وسط المدينه اذ تتمركز القوات
الروسيه الى الشرق والشمال منه بعد
سيطرتها على المنطقه الصناعيه شمالا في
حين تتمدرس القوات الاوكرانيه في الجهه
المقابله غربا ومع تصاعدي سخونه المعارك
والتصريحات حول المدينه التي تشهد اطول
معركه في الحرب الاوكرانيه لا شيء مؤكد
فيها حتى اللحظه الا صوت الرصاص والموت
رائد المصطفى العربيه
[موسيقى]
افدى موقع واكسوس الامريكيه ان الولايات
المتحده ناقشت مع الاوروبيين
والاسرائيليين اقتراحا للوصول الى اتفاق
مؤقت مع ايران ونقلت اكسوس عن مصادر قولها
ان الاتفاق يتضمن تجميد ايران لاجزاء من
برنامجها النووي مقابل تخفيف بعض العقوبات
وقال مسؤولون اسرائيليون وغربيون
وامريكيون لاكسيوس ان الاقتراح يشمل وقف
ايران تخصيب اليورانيوم عند درجه نقاء 60%
فيما اكد مسؤول اسرائيلي ان اسرائيل رفضت
هذه الفكره وايضا رفض ايرانيون الاقتراح
واكدوا تمسكهم باتفاق لا يقل عن اتفاق عام
قرر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو
تاجيل اقاله وزير الدفاع
بسبب الوضع الامني في البلاد وافاد مراسل
العربيه بان نتنياهو لم يقل جالنت رسميا
ولم يسلمه رساله اقاله خطيه موقعه بل
ابلغه ذلك شفهيا
وفي شان متصل اعلن قاده الائتلاف الحكومي
في اسرائيل وقاده المعارضه في تصريح
المشترك ان هناك تفاؤلا حذرا بشان
المحادثات التي جرت بينهما في منزل الرئيس
الاسرائيلي التصريح المشترك اكد اتفاق
الطرفين على ضروره الوصول الى حل طويل
الامد مع توضيح ان كل الاطراف الاسرائيليه
تدرك معنى عدم التوصل الى اتفاق وطني
واضاف التصريح المشترك على محادثات
ستستانف بعد عطله عيد الفصح
الى ذلك شدد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
نتنياهو على ضروره ابقاء السياسه خارج
بوابات المعسكرات والتوحد من اجل بقاء
اسرائيل على حد قوله وخلال كلمه له في
قعده عسكريه برفقه وزير الدفاع اكد
نتنياهو اهميه الحفاظ على قدرات الجيش
للدفاع عن اسرائيل ضد اي تهديدات على حد
تعبيره
هذا ورفعت اسرائيل حاله التاهب برا وجوا
على الحدود الشماليه بعد اسقاط مسيره
ايرانيه بسلاح الكتروني شمال مدينه طبريه
في الجليل ويرى مراقبون ان هذه المسيره
جاءت في اطار الرد على غارات اسرائيليه
متلاحقه ادت الى مقتل ضابطين ايرانيين
والى استهداف مخازن المسيرات الايرانيه
المعدله لحزب الله في مطار الضبعه في حمص
ولم يستبعد مراقبون ان تشهد الجبهه
الشماليه مزيدا من الغارات في الفتره
القريبه زياد حلبي
نحن في الجولان المحتل حيث يسود
تاين عسكري جوا وبرا ايضا بعد ان كانت
اسرائيل اسقطت مسيره ايرانيه فوق الجليل
كانت انطلقت من الاراضي السوريه وذلك اعقب
ايضا غارات اسرائيليه متكرره طال اخرها
مطار الضبعه قربه حمص حيث مخازن للمسيرات
الايرانيه التابعه لحزب الله هناك والتي
يعتقد بانها كانت غارات جاءت ردا على
عمليه مجدو التي اتهمت فيها اسرائيل حزب
الله الاجواء تبقى متوتره للغايه على
الجبهه الشماليه المرجح ان تكون هناك
المزيد من الغارات الاسرائيليه في العمق
السوري وتخشى اسرائيل ايضا من ردود محتمله
خاصه بسلاح المسيرات
وهنا ايضا على حدود لبنان تسود حاله تاهب
منذ عمليه ماجدو الاخيره التي حاولت
اسرائيل ان ترد عليها في الجغرافيا
السوريه وتدعي اسرائيل بان حزب الله عاد
نشر قواته في المنطقه الحدوديه على النحو
الذي سبق حرب تموز عام 2006 وبين هذا
وذاكر مراقبون بان كل الاطراف تنفذ هجمات
بدون ان تتبنى ايا منها بهدف خلق معادله
ردع تمنع الجانب الاخر من الرد او الهجوم
زياد حلبي العربيه الحدود اللبنانيه
[موسيقى]
والى ملفنا التالي في تسع هذا المساء
فيروس ماربورج بعد ان حضرت صحه العلميه من
خطر تحول فيروس مارك الى جائحه عالميه دعا
مركز مكافحه الامراض الامريكيه المواطنين
المسافرين الى غينيا الاستوائيه وتنزانيا
الى اتخاذ كافه الاجراءات الصحيه اللازمه
لتجنب الاصابه بالمرض الفتاك هذا وكانت
الدول العربيه اوسط مثل السعوديه
والامارات والكويت وعمان اوسط مواطنيها
بتاجيل السفر في الوقت الحالي الى تنزانيا
وغينيا الاستوائيه
معنى مباشره من دار السلام الصحفيه
شكرا لك على انضمامك الينا في التاسع هذا
المساء من العربيه بدايه اخر المعطيات
لديك حول اعداد الاصابات وكيف تتعامل
السلطات مع هذه الحالات
نحن نعرف بانه لغايه السادس اكتشفت
الحكومه ثمانيه اصابات
لاحقا وبعد خمسه ايام
قالت بانهم مصابون بفيروس
خمسه اشخاص من بينهم توفوا وثمانيه في
حاله تعافي من المرض ولكن من هؤلاء او
بسبب هذا الرقم قالت الحكومه بانها سوف
تقوم بتتبع المخالطين هؤلاء الذين خالطوا
المصابين بالفيروس في شمال شرقي تنزانيا
في منطقه كاجيرا وقام بالفعل بتتبع
المخالطين والى الان وصل العدد الى خمسه
اشخاص
ممن وضعوا في حاله الحجر
وخمسه اشخاص في تنزانيا وحدها هل لديك اي
معلومات عن غينيا
بينما نتحدث الان ليست اي معلومات من هناك
ولكن الدول اخرى مثل اوغندا ايضا والدول
الا جوار كلها في حاله تاهب
بسبب
وهذه المنطقه بالتحديد
التي شهدت التفشي هذه
الاصابه وهذا الفيروس
بلغت التقارير عنها مثلا نيوغندا التي كان
فيها
او بعض الاشخاص في شمال الشرقيه تنزانيا
والبعض كان اعتقد بان هذا هو بالفعل فيروس
ايفولو ولكن الحكومه اكدت من انه فيروس
مارفل وليس ايبولا
منظمه الصحه العالميه ايزيك حذرت من
احتماليه تحول الى جائحه عالميه ازاء هذا
التحذير هل هناك اي معطيات اذا كانت
تنزانيا تستعد لفرض اغلاق او حظر تجوال
بسبب تسجيل هذه الاعداد من مارب بورك في
تنزانيا
من الحكومه هو ان الارقام لم تتزايد وعدد
الاشخاص المصابين لا يولون فقط ثمانيه
خمسه واربعه من نفس العائله وثلاثه منهم
في حاله تعافي لا توجد اي حالات او اصابات
جديده الى الان والتي هو خمسه اشخاص من
الذين
يعتبرون المخالطين وضعوا في الحجر ولكن ما
قامت به الحكومه ايضا هو انها اصدرت بعض
الارشادات الخاصه بالسفر والدول حتى في
الشرق الاوسط
يراقبون ويتبعون المسافرين القادمين الى
البلاد والخارجي منها سواء عبر
البريه وكذلك الجويه ويطلب مك
الاستمارات وهنالك رقم مجاني ايضا قدم لهم
لضمان اي اعراض
قريبه او مشابهه
يتم الافاده عنها ولكن الى الان لم تكن
هنالك اي انباء عن اي اصابات جديده
والحكومه بدورها لم تعلن عن اي
نيه لاغلاق البلاد
وعلى الارجح لن تحصل هذه الحاله هنا خاصه
مع التقارير التي اصدرتها الحكومه حيث
قالت انها تسيطر على الوضع
وتقول بانها في حاله مراقبه ولكنها لن
تخاطر باي شيء نعم اشكرك شكرا جزيلا صحفيه
تنزاني
كنت معنا مباشره من دار السلام في تنزانيا
[موسيقى]
في تسجيل مسرب جديد لرئيس الوزراء العراقي
الاسبق نور المالكي قال انه اشترى طائرات
عراقيه مقاتله من نوع سوخوي كانت تحتجزها
ايران كما اشار لقيام قاسم سليماني بنصب
قواعد لطائرات المسيره في العراق وبحسب
المقطع المسرب فان التصريحات كانت بعد
لقاء اجراه مع احد القنوات او احدى
القنوات العراقيه المحليه
احتجنا طائرات مقاتله لانه طائرات
بالجزيره راسا حجي اسف السيده القائد قال
العراقي احمد
وهكذا احتجنا طائرات مسير راسا عندما
الطائرات مسيره ونصابها فورا اليوم نطلب
السلاح حتى اخر اخر لقاء كان هو مهدي من
طلعوا كنا نقعد
على هالدرجات مات الغرفه يكون واقع
الاتفاقيات مال السلاح
هكذا كانت المساله تمشي بالنسبه لنا لانه
المعركه شرسه ومدعومه وهي انتفا
[موسيقى]
ضه
اعلنت الحكومه الاستراليه موافقه الرئيس
الوزراء انطوني البانيز على حظر استخدام
تطبيق تيك توك على الهواتف الحكوميه بعد
تقارير لوزاره الداخليه كما ستخضع حكومه
ولايه فيكتوريا الى قرار حظر تيك توك وفقا
لوسائل الاعلام استراليا وياتي القرار
الاسترالي بعد حظر دول عديده بينها
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا استخدام تيك
توك من الاجهزه الرسميه بسبب مخاوف امنيه
اتسع هذا المساء مستمرا نتابع فيها بعد
فاصل
نحو عشره ملايين معتمر في الحرم المكي
خلال اول عشره ايام من رمضان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
الشريفين عن تسجيل قرابه 10 ملايين معتمر
ومصلي وزائر توافدوا الى الحرم المكي خلال
العشر الاوائل من شهر رمضان لاول مره منذ
جائحه كورونا وعلمت الجهات المعنيه في
السعوديه عملت على توفير عدد من الخدمات
داخل المسجد الحرام اضافه الى انشاء معارض
حيه لخدمات الزوار والمعتمرين والتوعيه
الميدانيه والرقميه والارشاديه وتوفير 15
مترجما وخدمه التطويف والخدمات الاجتماعيه
والانسانيه
[موسيقى]
معنا مباشره من الحرم المكي الشريف
مراسلنا هاني الصفيان هاني اهلا بك معنا
اذا في هذه الليله الرمضانيه كما نتابع من
خلفك حشود كبيره من المعتمرين والرقم كما
اعلنتها السلطات عشره ملايين معتمر وزائر
زاروا الحرم المسجد الحرام في العشر
الاوائل من رمضان كيف يتم تسيير هذه
الاعداد الكبيره من الزوار والمعتمرين
نعم اهلا بك صهيب واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه قد يزيد الرقم عن العشره ملايين
ليصل الى اكثر من عشره ملايين ونصف
المليون مؤتمر وزائر زارو المسجد الحرام
في مكه المكرمه من اول ايام رمضان حتى هذا
اليوم الاعداد ما زالت في تزايد الارقام
لاول مره تسجل نستطيع ان نقول ايضا انه
الكثافه العديديه مستمره ورغم هذه الكثافه
العدديه الا ان عمليه تنظيم دخولهم وكذلك
خروجهم هي تتم وفق الخطه التشغينيه التي
ادتها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين مع امن الحج
والعمره عموما مع هذه الكثافه العدديه
لابد من وجود مشاريع نفذتها السعوديه من
اجل
من اجل ان تكون مناسبه لهذه الاعداد
الكبيره فمثلا انا اتواجد في احد الساحات
التي خصصتها السعوديه وهي تعتبر من ضمن
المشاريع السعوديه اليوم نتحدث عن انجاز
في التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه حققت بنسبه
90% ونتحدث ايضا ما زالت المشاريع مستمره
وهذه احدى المشاريع من خلال بنايه او
عماره المنارات التي ما زالت تنفذ هنا في
المسجد الحرام ولا يبلغ طول المناره
الواحده اكثر من 130 مترا نتحدث ايضا عن
مشاريع انجاز حققتها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
في صحن المطاف او تحديدا في مشاريع المطاف
ما نسبته 75% اليوم عندما نشاهد ايضا
الكثافه العدديه
وايضا مع عدد الابواب الموجوده في الحرم
المكي لم يتم استخدام فقط الا 166 ابابا
من اصل 220 بابا نعم سهيل نعم شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاهد الحيه اذا مباشره من
الحرم المكي الشريف معاصر العربيه نصفين
وكما تبعنا مع هاني وبعد تشغيل الحرم
المكي بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه بموسم
عمره هذا العام تركزت عمليات نقل
المعتمرين والمصلين من والى الحرم المكي
على منظومه النقل العامه بمكه اذ جهزت
3000 او ثلاثه الاف حافله تعمل على نقل
اكثر من مليون و 200 الف شخص يوميا الى
المسجد الحرام وذلك لتسهيل على الزوار
وتخفيف التكدس المروري في طرقات العاصمه
[موسيقى]
مع دخول شهر رمضان تضاعفت عمليات التنقل
من والى الحرم المكي وداخلي مكه ما جعل
القطاعات الامنيه والخدميه تعمل على تنفيذ
خطط منظومه النقل العام حتى تضمن
الانسيابيه والراحه للمعتمرين والمصلين
احنا الان مشاركين تقريبا ب 2350 حافله
وعلى استعداد انه احنا نوفر وفق الخطه
التشغيل المعتمده 3000 حافله لخدمه هذه
المنظومه بشكل كامل المعدل اليومي لنقل
الركاب تقريبا من مليون الى مليون و200
راكب تختلف ان نسبها وتفاوتها ما بين ايام
ونهايه الاسبوع خمس محطات نقل رئيسيه على
مداخل مكه التي تمكن المعتمرين والمصلين
من ايقاف مركباتهم واستخدام النقل العام
للحرم المكي اضافه الى تسعه مواقف نقل
داخليه تساهم في ايصال المستفيدين من داخل
مكه الى الحرم المواقف الداخليه هي مواقف
قريبه من الحرم المده الزمنيه للنقل ما
بيتجاوز العشر دقائق من يوم ما يوقف
سيارته الى ان يصعد الحافله ومن ثم اتجاهه
الى الحرم وابرزها مواقف
ساحه كدانه هذه من ابرز المواقف بالاضافه
الى موقف الزاهر
وموقف دقمه الوبر في الجانب الاخر يعمل
مشروع حافلات مكه على تقديم افضل وسيله
للنقل العام عبر 12 مسارا تغطي الشوارع
الرئيسيه والفرعيه والشوارع الممتده بين
الاحياء ويلعب دورا هاما في تقليل اعداد
السيارات في شوارع وطرقات مكه في موسم
العمره
من مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي العربيه
[موسيقى]
في دراما رمضان يحقق الموسم الثالث من
مسلسل للموت ثلاثه نجاحا كبيرا وتفاعلا من
قبل الجمهور لا يقل عن النجاح الذي حققه
العمل في المواسم الماضيه نسخه المسلسل
هذا العام شهد ظهور شخصيه جديده باحداث
دراميه مثيره فيما اكدت مؤلفه المسلسل
نادين جابر ان الجزء الثالث استكمال لاحدث
الجزء الاول والثاني منه فهو متصل ومنفصل
عنها في ذات الوقت
[موسيقى]
كتبنا حي التاني
تاريخ عم بعيد نفسه كل وحده مريضه
مرحبا عاد مسلسل الموت هذا العام بجزء
الثالث وعلى مقياس الجماهيري لم يستطع
العمل ان يحظى بنفس التفاعل اللي حدا به
خلال الموسمين السابقين على مواقع التواصل
طبعا مع عوده البطلتين ماجي بوصن ودانيلا
رحمه من الموت وغياب عدد من اهم ابطال
للعمل سابقا ابرزهم باسم مغني مسلسل للموت
وكاريكتور سحر كم مصري اعطاني كتير اعطاني
كتير على الصعيد المهني وعلى الصعيد
الشخصي انا هيدي الشخصيه حبيتها واتعلمت
منها القوه تعلمت منها كتير وعلى الصعيد
المهني حطني بمحل
اعلى يمكن من المحل خطوط خطوات لقدام في
كان منافس شرس للموت وصل للعالميه حتى عم
يترجم عم يتدبلج وعم يترجم لعده لغات وعم
ينحدر بكل دول العالم وهذا الشيء بكبر
القلب صراحه تاتي احداث مسلسل للموت للجزء
الثالث في رمضان اللي تكمل احداث الجزئين
السابقين في اطار متصل ومنفصل في ذات
الوقت حيث يشارك في الجزء الثالث الشخصيات
جديده باحداث دراميه مثيره غرفتنا بمحل في
تنوع كثير كبير في شخصيات كتير جديده
وشخصيات مش بس فايتين هيك يعني مش شخصيات
بتمرق مرور الكرام لا في شخصيات عن جد
فعلا حتعلم هالسنه اللي مكتوب كتير حلو
التصوير والانتاج
والتونس رحنا على تونس وصورنا
بتوينز مشاهد رائعه كل العوامل هيك ثقيله
هالسنه هي دراما عربيه فيها اكثر من جنسيه
هي بالنسبه لالا انا بعتبرها مكسب لان انا
بتعلم من غيري وغيره بتعلم مني فهيدا
الاختلاط
هو اللي بخليك انت يكون عندك
نضج لانك انت عم تشوف الاخر والاخر عم
بيشوفك العمل بسبب جزئيه السابقين
وجماهيريه ابطاله استطاع الحفاظ على عدد
كبير من جمهوره بالاضافه لفئه جديده فماذا
قال جمهور للموت عن هذا الجزء تحديدا
[موسيقى]
الحياه مثل البيانو
بتعرفي تلعبي
[موسيقى]
قام العلماء بتصوير سمكه تسبح على عمق غير
عادي في المحيط الهادئ قباله جنوب اليابان
ما يجعلها اعمق ملاحظه من هذا النوع يتم
اجراءها على الاطلاق وتم تصويره سمكه
الحلزون وهي تسبح على عمق
836 مترا وبحسب الخبراء فان هذه السمكه قد
تكون قريبه جدا من اقصى عمق يمكن لاي سمكه
البقاء فيه على قيد الحياه
[موسيقى]
ومن اعماق المحيطات الى الفضاء حيث كشفت
وكاله ناسا عن اسماء رواد الفضاء الاربعه
المقرر سفرهم الى القمر بحلول نهايه العام
المقبل من بينهم امراه وثلاثه رجال وعينت
ناسا اول امراه واول امريكيه من اصل
افريقي
كرائدتي فضاء في مهمه قمريه وقدمتهما كجزء
من فريق مكون من اربعه اعضاء اختيروا
للطيران في اول رحله ماهوله حول القمر منذ
اكثر من خمسين عاما
التاسعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بعناوينها
ترامب يتوجه الى نيويورك تمهيدا لمثوله
امام المحكمه غدا العالم يترقب محاكمه
القرن
والبيت الابيض يؤكد عدم رصد اي تهديدات
بسبب محاكمه ترامبو ويشدد على يقظه
الاجهزه الامنيه
تستعد للانضمام غدا لحلف النيتو رسميا
وروسيا تؤكد تعزيز وجودها العسكري
واستراليا احدث المنضمين لمقاطعه تيك توك
حظر قريب للتطبيق على الاجهزه الحكم
التاسعه انتهت ولكن الفتره الاخباريه
المسائيه على العربيه مستمره الان الى 360
واليوم نرحبنا بطاهر ليلا نرحب ب راويه
القاسم مره اخرى اذا في 360 مساء الخير
مرحبا بكم اهلا فيك صهيبنا نقول الحمد لله
على السلامه
لا صوت يعلو في امريكا والعالم ربما على
ترقب هذا الحدث التاريخي الهام بدون شك
نبته عينا عليه وكذلك وكذلك معركه بخموت
الى اين وصلت خاصه في ظل سيطرت قوات فاغنر
على المبنى الاداري للمدينه وعوده اتابع
بعدكما تطورات هذه الملفات ايضا في اخبار
الساعه ان شاء الله شكرا